kamilla Kibeho celebrates Shawn Mendes
his 21st birthday with a big fat suit
and some instil of on Friday the 22 year
old singer took to Instagram to share
this throwback pic of her and her
rumoured beau she captioned the shot
quote happy birthday to this magic human
I love you I'm really happy and I feel
very I don't I feel like really in touch
with my emotions the sweet bday post
comes just one day after Shawn
celebrated the milestone occasion in NYC
where he rented out Harriet's rooftop
and lounge an eye witness tells et that
the bash kicked off around 10:00 p.m.
and the guests sing him the birthday
song as he was presented with this cake
featuring replicas of the essential
items found in his dressing room on tour
according to the eyewitness Shawn
appeared to have a ton of fun even
telling the partygoers that he was too
drunk to give a speech after they sang
to him then there was this moment
[Applause]
yeah that's Camilla laying a big steamy
kiss on the birthday boy let's watch
that again shall we
yeah and the eye witness tells et that
Camilla was by Sean's side all night but
their birthday PDA is just the latest in
a string of affectionate outings for the
seniorita singers in July a source told
et that the two are quote committed to
working on a relationship
adding Shawn and Camilla originally were
just enjoying spending time together and
having a summer fling
Camilla had just got out of a
relationship and Shawn was in the middle
of a massive tour however Shawn and
Camilla have really fallen for one
another
[Music]